idraulici salverà nel mondo lo so detta
così potrebbe sembrare una formazione
estemporanea senza senso illogica ma io
ci credo talmente tanto da avere
addirittura scritto un manuale a cui ho
dato esattamente lo stesso titolo e
questa mia convinzione parte in un'epoca
lontana quando ero un bambino e ho avuto
la fortuna di passare tantissimo tempo
in compagnia di mio nonno perché passare
il tempo in compagnia dei nonni è una
fortuna hanno tante storie da raccontare
mio nonno era una persona umile di
mestiere faceva il muratore e ha sempre
avuto la volontà forse la necessità di
costruire un mattone alla volta la
nostra base solida e quando intendo
nostra intendo a livello familiare lui
credeva nella famiglia trasferendoci dei
pensieri positivi delle esperienze
concrete
solo che lui aveva un modo di fare
questa cosa che era a mio avviso
straordinario lui ci raccontava delle
storie e queste storie non erano le
classiche favole ma erano le storie
delle storie inventate
fondamentalmente era bravissimo nel
mischiare la realtà e la fantasia e
riusciva a creare dei veri e propri
episodi sempre con la fine una sorta di
morale qualcosa davvero utile e
ovviamente capibile per quel che era
l'età della persona con cui le stava
parlando
era veramente una persona incredibile
oggi
i tempi sono cambiati ma io mi ricordo
queste storie del ricordo con affetto
chiaramente mi ricordo anche con affetto
che già ai tempi quando ero un bambino
perché questa cosa iniziò all'incirca
quando avevo 6 anni mi ritrovai di
fronte ad una situazione abbastanza
simpatica che vi invita ad immaginare vi
ricordate la classica domanda che
sicuramente avranno posta che cosa vuoi
fare da grande e tutti quanti mi ricordo
i miei compagni all astronauta lo
scienziato il pompiere l'avvocato il
medico è alzato la mano è letteralmente
come entusiasmo l'idraulico davvero e
questa cosa mi ha veramente colpito
anche perché non nego che guardare gli
sguardi delle persone che ascoltavano
questa mia affermazione che vedeva
qualcosa di più no no è di più cioè per
me è assolutamente eccezionale è un
lavoro straordinario perché mio nonno
lanciava sempre un affermazione perché
lui mi consigliava di diventare un
idraulico ed era da lì che io attingevo
questa esperienza perché è normale lui
mister faceva il muratore fatica e per
lui le persone che non facevano fatica
nel suo contesto erano gli idraulici che
erano loro gli elettricisti idraulici ma
l'idraulico
in particolare gli aveva passato quella
sensazione no di un lavoro con una certa
professionalità guadagnavi bene forse
una volta non lo so sicuramente però si
garantiva un tipo di attività sempre
utile e quindi lui proprio mi diceva
diventano idraulico vincenzo perché ti
troverai sempre bene avrai sempre da
poter lavorare fondamentale lavorare no
per sostenersi e io ho fatto mia piano
piano un passo alla volta
anno dopo anno questa sua convinzione
questa sua affermazione
ora se mi cercate online così io non
faccio l'idraulico però faccio un lavoro
trasversale che cosa vuol dire vuol dire
che io sono una sorta di ponte di
comunicazione
tra gli idraulici e tutta la parte
relativa ai professionisti che gravitano
intorno agli idraulici e da lì il
manuale il manuale è un proprio è un
traduttore in un certo qual modo no
quindi ho un po creato o reso più
tecnologico forse visto che qua siamo in
un contesto dove si parla di tecnologia
o reso più tecnologico quello che era un
consiglio base lanciato da una persona
che mi voleva assolutamente bene quindi
in un certo qual modo ho fatto un po no
quello che mi era stato consigliato
però io ho anche detto che il contesto
oggi è cambiato
viviamo in un mondo veramente complesso
fateci caso notizie dei telegiornali
sono sempre difficili da digerire
ci piacciono le serie televisive cruente
guardiamo su queste piattaforme digitale
basta guardare i titoli a e poi per
rilassarci
andiamo al cinema a guardare film dei
supereroi è questa questa visione che vi
ho appena raccontato mi è proprio
scattata durante l'ennesimo film dei
supereroi che mi stava accingendo a
vedere era in coda al cinema per vedere
il 22esimo film dei supereroi 22esimo
già dice lunga
quanti quanti ne hanno fatti avengers
and game film della marvel e il mio
cervello iniziò a scollegarsi dalla
realtà da quello che stavo facendo tante
che era la fila in quel momento era
talmente lunga che invece aveva inizio a
ragionare come quando guidate
all'automobile un certo punto vi
ritrovate a un'altra parte
arrivati a destinazione senza ricordarvi
della strada più o meno questo è un po
il ragionamento succede spesso e in
tanti contesti ma in quel momento il mio
cervello inizio a pensare che fila
interminabile come mai è un film di
supereroi errori e per vederlo e
adolescenziale e attira tutto a queste
persone
ma come mai cosa che spinge l'industria
cinematografica a concentrare
l'attenzione su questa tipologia di film
beh allora si chiama industria
cinematografica probabilmente la spinge
il guadagno no il 22esimo film già ce la
stava dicendo lunga la coda
interminabile mi stava rispondendo al
discorso economico e poi sapere che
avengers endgame proprio quel film è
stato campioni da un punto è stato un
campione da un punto di vista del
maggior incasso ma è raccolto nella
storia con 2 miliardi e 800 milioni di
dollari
vuol dire che a livello planetario
questa tipologia di film ci piace e
quindi invece belen ciò propormi una
serie di risposte del perché io fossi
leader perché ovviamente non conosceva
quei tempi il record d'incassi ma erano
talmente tanti perché che cosa ci spinge
illuminazione noi abbiamo bisogno di
essere salvati
provate a pensarci cosa fanno i
supereroi ci salvano in generale no
catastrofi non dico attacchi di nemici
perché aveva però i supereroi come
compito quello di salvarci bene ma
allora perché noi troviamo conforto noi
adulti a non bambini noi adulti troviamo
con forti in questa tipologia di film
perché noi abbiamo bisogno di essere
salvati ma da chi l'ho detto prima noi
siamo circondati da notizie negative e
difficili da digerire no crisi climatica
tu da solo
sarete in grado di risolvere la crisi
climatica do io la risposta però
indicato una caso no bene e allora un
supereroe
ecco che potrebbe fare realmente la
differenza se solo esistesse mari invasi
dalla plastica e adesso mi metto
raccolgo tutte le bottiglie da sì certo
fallo perché
quello è auspicabile no però ha visto
non ha visto in una chiave generale ci
sentiamo veramente impotenti il
supereroe e questo ovviamente è una mia
visione la mia interpretazione ci fanno
sentire chiaramente un pochino meglio ci
fanno sentire un po un po protegge bene
però ci siamo arrivati fino a questo
punto c'è mai invasi dalla plastica
crisi climatica e come ci siamo arrivati
chi al cattivo della storia
i cattivi di questa storia che
tecnicamente i supereroi dovrebbero
sconfiggere siamo noi siamo noi che
stiamo utilizzando questo pianeta no
sentiamo tutti i giorni non vi sto
raccontando un qualcosa di nuovo ma
perché siamo arrivati lì volontariamente
abbiamo inquinato il nostro pianeta o
l'abbiamo fatto inconsciamente qualcuno
io e l'ha fatto volontariamente sta
inquinando volontariamente oggi
inquinerà volontariamente domani lo
faranno certo
e allora la cosa che ci ha portato fino
a questo punto in una buona quota parte
è stata la ricerca del comfort è stata
la ricerca del comfort
pensateci l'esempio più banale torna a
casa la sera
apro la porta fuori fa freddo da se in
questo periodo poi un po invernale la
umidità torna a casa entro che cosa
voglio trovare io voglio turbare il
calore del focolare fraia dalla casa non
si fa con la famiglia è bello mi scalda
sapere che ci sono delle persone che mi
vogliono bene
mestre la casa in quel momento lì e fred
e fredda non già una decina di storia e
noi viviamo in un contesto oggi dove
privarci del calore fisico della casa ci
risulta proprio impossibile da concepire
mio nonno aveva una stufa a legna non
tornava a casa trovando la calda ci
metteva la legna e già era oro ai tempi
quindi questa tecnologia che si è voluta
veramente
in maniera molto veloce negli ultimi
anni ci ha portato ad avere diversi
vantaggi reali tangibili vantaggi che
addirittura ci hanno fatto ingannare
l'evoluzione umana
questa cosa potrebbe sembrare un po
strana di sodio l'evoluzione ci mette
centinaia migliaia di anni no
ecco noi siamo stati così tanti
intelligenti noi umani da riuscire a
ingannare l'evoluzione tant'è che citi
una notizia è uscita sul national
geographic nel 2012
vado a parafrasare la perché chiaramente
a memoria dentro un po complesso però
recitava più o meno così se in un epoca
preindustriale la vita media dura va a
32 anni
oggi la vita media ne dura 72 sembra
poco ma poco non è
noi abbiamo raddoppiato la nostra stessa
esistenza abbiamo trovato l'elisir di
lunga vita
e l'abbiamo trovato in un confort
principalmente legato alla tecnologia a
servizio nostro che passa attraverso
tutta una serie di canali
guardate vi faccio un esempio molto
molto intuitivo velocissimo che non è
per forza allegato all'idraulico in sé
di cui oggi ovviamente tra poco capirete
perché ho fatto questi link ma la vita
si è allungata anche solo perché siamo
in grado di conservare le medicine gli
organi come li conserviamo noi li
conserviamo grazie al circuito frigo che
ha una tecnologia a un frigorifero detto
proprio brutalmente no che è una
tecnologia abbastanza recente veramente
super recente ecco senza questa
tecnologia probabilmente avremmo avuto
più difficoltà nell allungarci la vita
ma anche nell'avere più confort più
vantaggi nella nostra stessa esistenza
però io sono partito dicendo gli
idraulici salveranno il mondo
adesso vi sto parlando di supereroi di
circuito frigo insomma rob è un po
strane no da collegare tra di loro però
sono passato attraverso la casa
attraverso il comfort della nostra casa
e chi costruisce fisicamente il comfort
all'interno delle nostre abitazioni
chi lo fa da un punto di vista del caldo
del freddo e dell'acqua calda sanitaria
a cui ci facciamo la doccia
lo fanno gli idraulici c'è un'altra
figura sono loro che fanno bene
affidarsi ad un professionista capace e
competente è fondamentale non tanto per
star meglio noi ma per usare meno
risorse primarie perché paradossalmente
nelle nostre abitazioni solo a livello
europeo e in europa noi siamo 740
milioni circa
entra il 40 per cento di tutta l'energia
che viene distribuito a livello europeo
nelle nei nostri edifici nelle nostre
case pensate quanto pesa questo confort
e la metà serve solo per scaldarci
capite la quantità di responsabilità che
queste persone hanno in mano come ce
l'avete mano tutti voi tutti noi perché
io non è che vivo in una casa fredda
quando ci chiedono di abbassare di un
grado la temperatura dei nostri ambienti
e perché la quantità
ovviamente di abitazioni mestre tutti
insieme se tutti noi dovessimo ascoltare
questo consiglio e spero che lo facciate
potrebbe realmente far la differenza
come in un mare tante gocce d'acqua
furono un'intesa limiterà
vastissima quantità di acqua è così che
funziona non c'è un'altra strada e
l'unione che fa la forza
sempre sempre chiaro ci può essere
singolo che fa la differenza ma la forza
alla pa l'unione e da qui io in prima
persona mi scontro è un incontro sere
dire sempre con questi professionisti
perché il mio compito è trasversale e
cerco davvero di convincerli ma lo
faccio col cuore
guarda che se ti chiedono di essere
certificate di studiare fallo perchè ti
serve per migliorare non solo tu ma
proprio migliorare a livello planetario
alle responsabilità enorme cui tutti i
tuoi colleghi messi insieme insieme a
noi utilizzatori possiamo fare una
differenza estrema estrema
ricordatevi l'energia a livello di
quantità che vi ho suggerito poc'anzi
la differenza è enorme bisogna prendere
coscienza di questa cosa qua e nel mio
piccolo appunto da lino l'idea di dargli
lo strumento che ho realizzato e che
oggi mi porta qui perché io sono qui
proprio grazie a questo strumento e sono
contento perché posso parlare a voi non
tanto dello strumento in sé ma
ricordandovi di fare la differenza anche
voi
chiaramente bene io però quando parlo di
salvare il pianeta mi immagino un eroe
no
bene gli idraulici lo sono a tutti gli
effetti perché è così che funziona e
addirittura essendo anche loro esseri
umani sono persone che potrebbero il
condizionale non tutti noi siamo uguali
avere un cuore enorme
e vi assicuro che ci sono delle persone
che fanno parte di questa categoria che
questo cuore ce l'hanno io non sono
non ho fatto parte del progetto di cui
adesso vi faccio vedere due slide e sarà
il progetto poi in realtà con cui
chiuderò questo mio auspicio ma ci
tenevo particolarmente a farvelo vedere
e ho chiesto la loro autorizzazione
chiaramente per poterlo fare perché è
uno dei tanti progetti che nascono da
queste consapevolezze che io vi ho
appena passato e che possono fare anche
loro la differenza
il progetto si chiama l'albero delle
caldaie e sostanzialmente è un progetto
che è stato realizzato da due distinte
associazioni di idraulici che hanno
fatto loro tutto quello che ci siamo
raccontati poco prima insieme a una
onlus che si chiama parchi per kyoto
il progetto è abbastanza semplice se io
in stallo in ogni casa un generatore di
calore questo consuma in un certo modo
dell'energia produce in un certo modo
una parte inquinante e non ne possiamo
fare a meno perché devo stare al caldo
devo poter avere dei confort che sono
quelli che ci aiutano metto in moto un
circuito un circolo interessante in
grado di poter contrastare quello che
sono le emissioni inquinanti prodotte da
quello che io ti sto installando
chiaramente più sarà efficiente nella
scelta dell'impianto nella scelta degli
strumenti che utilizzerò meno incline ro
ma comunque il progetto in sé
interessante perché per ogni generatore
che loro vanno a installare propongono
di piantare un albero e ogni albero
piantato nel suo intero ciclo di vita
riesce a trasformare fino a mediamente
in realtà fino a 700 chilogrammi di
anidride carbonica allora io vorrei
concludere con un invito prima di tutto
vi ricorda davvero usate con attenzione
e parsimonia questo straordinario
strumento come l'impianto in sé ma in
generale tutto quello che di crea
confort usatela con attenzione perché
bisogna aver cura di quello che ci fa
stare bene e non è mai approfittarsene e
se ce la fate tentate anche voi un
albero perché nella vita comunque far
del bene anche in maniera indiretta è
una cosa sempre che uno così deve far
propria come sentimento io ho proprio
voglia passare piantato un albero perché
così in maniera indiretta andrete ad
aiutare il pianeta e voi stessi
grazie mille
[Applauso]